I alluded to this yesterday on the [inaudible]
members only bonus Joe, that there's growing
concern among Donald from staffers about how
they can avoid confusing him and the extent
to which Donald Trump is confused of bull
is a growing area of concern for the people
that are working around him on a daily basis.
One such example is that Donald Trump's aides
were looking for Twitter to put in place a
15 minute delay on Donald Trump's tweets such
that they could maybe be canceled or fixed
or modified before they go out.
I'll get to that in a moment.
But there's a really interesting storyline
that's growing from reporting by Politico
and others about how Donald Trump is being
kept away from certain people simply to avoid
confusing him.
And it's like dealing with a nine year old
kid.
And in fact, I would argue it's actually like
dealing with a cognitively limited nine year
old kid.
Here's an example.
Shortly after Ukrainian, president Zelenskyi
was elected, um, an actual Ukraine expert.
The whistleblower that we now know as Lieutenant
Colonel Alexander Veneman, who's at the center
of a lot of controversy right now.
Then men was set to brief Donald Trump about
Zelenskyi.
Why?
Well, it made sense.
Veneman is an actual Ukraine expert.
Trump needs to know what's going on in Ukraine.
It makes sense to have an expert brief Trump
about that issue.
Trump staffers at the last second told Veneman,
you know what?
Don't show up.
Trump will become confused by your presence
because Donald Trump is under the impression
that this other guy Kashyap Patel is actually
the expert on Ukraine.
Now, what's hilarious is that Kashyap Patel
is not an expert on Ukraine.
Patel was a Devin Nunez staffer, Devin Nunez.
Of course, the completely bogus and and disgusting
and depraved, uh, Republican Congressman,
uh, Kashyap Patel has no expertise on Ukraine.
He has no knowledge on Ukraine.
But Donald Trump believed that Kashyap Patel
was the expert on Ukraine.
And staffers said, you know, if Veneman shows
up to talk to Trump about Ukraine, Trump will
become confused.
So they tell Veneman don't show up, even though
Veneman is actually the Ukraine expert.
This is tragic.
This is sad, but it's also disturbing when
it comes to, in order to avoid confusing Trump,
people who aren't actually our real experts
on subject matter are being chosen to brief
Trump and the real subject matter experts
are being kept out of the entire thing.
Here's another example.
It's the Twitter thing, which I mentioned
Donald Trump's AIDS.
At one point, we're considering asking Twitter
to effectively reprogram the way that the
platform works just for Donald Trump's to
instate a 15 minute delay on Donald Trump's
tweets.
This was earlier in Trump's presidency, and
they wanted to do it without Trump's knowledge.
And what was going on is that Donald Trump's
tweeting was obviously so problematic from
day one and star staffers were struggling
with how to manage it.
Trump was obviously not going to allow someone
have the power to, okay or not okay his tweets.
So the idea was let's secretly go to Twitter
and let's have them put a 15 minute delay
on Donald Trump's tweets.
And during those 15 minutes, staffers presumably
would be able to either edit tweets, delete
them, talk Trump out of them, whatever the
case may be.
Understand the scope of this where Trump is
so erratic in his behavior, but also react
so negatively to any attempt at controlling
or modifying his behavior that staff were
looking at asking one of the largest social
media platforms in the world to program in
functionality just for Donald Trump's account
specifically to avoid the embarrassment and
problems that Donald Trump's tweeting was
causing.
Never mind, by the way, how potentially abused
the tool could be.
Imagine if you are one of Trump's staffers
and you see that Donald Trump writes a tweet
and you've got 15 minutes to act on that tweet
and you know that it's a tweet that could,
for example, Hank, the stock price of a publicly
traded company.
During those 15 minutes, you could go and
short that stock to make a financial gain
windfall really from what you now can predict
pretty safely.
Because Donald Trump's tweets move, the markets
will be an upcoming shift in a share price.
It's dangerous.
It's stunning that this is something that
they would, they would even consider asking
a platform like Twitter to do.
And the reality is something that we've known
for a long time.
The people around Donald Trump have to treat
the guy like as I said, a poorly behaved or
even cognitively limited kid despite the fact
that he is, you know, a wealthy 73 year old
white guy, a born with a silver spoon in his
mouth who has not ever known any actual, uh,
um, adversity in his entire life and yet still
believes that he is the greatest victim of
the unfairness of the world.
As he constantly talks about witch hunts and
presidential harassment and how unfairly he's
treated by the media.
It is like dealing with a kid.
That is what staffers are increasingly describing,
sad but dangerous as well.